the stocks we go
[Applause]
is the attack trying to stand in front
but look at just too much skill with a
little hang time that time in the finish
[Music]
is the attack trying to stand in front
but look at just too much skill is so
weird
Bam's by comparison have taken a 36
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
has been blips in the game look at Lucca
yeah look at it
nothing but net
[Applause]
[Music]
are we having fun yet how about that
Lukas's that's fun basketball will again
[Music]
it's down to three wicked clouds of
sweet
[Applause]
here when you start talking about
fourth-quarter story right around
Lillard nice little crossover and got to
the rim for an easy finish
we hear when you start talking about
fourth-quarter story right around
Lillard watch the screen Powell will set
it ten left on the shot clock
defender writing Luka to the basket
[Music]
on shots to tie or take the lead in the
last two minutes of the fourth quarter
well and the way he was able to finish